I said it's only 20 minutes but we're
having to eat along so this this picture
here is actually that's the hill where
we got stuff isn't it tell us what
happened on the hill so
we got stuck on the hill
everyone
so it was sort of really cool
then as we were driving
everyone started to like stop and we
started to like fall behind skid into
bushes
when we were skidding into the bushes
it's really stuck and then people with
bigger cars thought they can make it but
they just drove in front of us and just
could just stopped moving so it was so
frustrating because we were on a hill
and lucky it was a residential Hill and
everybody was coming out that lives on
there because obviously they've seen
this before and we're Towing people up
the hill but somebody sort of everybody
kept trying to get in front of us so we
kept moving down the list so we went
from being really excited about the snow
didn't we tend to how did we feel in
that car sure just like there's nothing
so how long were you guys actually stuck
for
um like a couple hours a couple of hours
we were stuck we were stuck for about
four so what happened was this again
this picture with a blue car this is an
abandoned car in front of us so we
abandoned that car didn't we because who
did we meet because we met
some snow angels some snow angels we
call them snow angels um Cheryl and
Jason who if they're listening this
morning I hope they got there they were
on their way to Rye on the a21 so
basically that's where it all serves
from the a21 that goes through Kent East
Sussex down to sort of Hastings way it
was just completely gridlocked the snow
came down so quickly cars were abandoned
everywhere nobody could get back could
they so Cheryl and Jason came to our car
saw that we had baby Ray in there she
was pretty good actually wasn't she
considering she was only a night in your
car
um and they gave us a lift to the main
road and then who was our big snow angel
at the end my dad yeah dressed like he
was going skiing and he managed to get
us onto the a21 he was just
appropriately we weren't where we did we
had trainers on and then we got to the
a21 and we were there for another hour
or so and we literally just lived off
the a21 but it went as far as the eye
could see and I was following a lady on
Twitter I hope she's okay I checked it
this morning when I woke up and at about
2 A.M she said she'd only just turned
off the a21 it was bad wasn't it yeah it
was
terrible but how do you feel we got home
I felt really good because it was Rey's
first experience in the snow and when
she was in the snow she was running
around and picking it up even though she
did get a bit wet because of the snow
yeah we've been in the car a long time
so I let them stretch their legs and run
about in the snow that they've been
desperate to be in we've just been stuck
in a car and that's our garden this
morning I mean that's unbelievable at
four o'clock yesterday afternoon nothing
and then all of that that's Fallen
overnight I'm sensing a snowball fight
coming at just a little bit later on yes
this is me officially calling it a snow
day Neil
not a chance um I know you will have
kept you'll catch the wee ones and
spirits up but you know raise up raise
our Eon a very very wee one you must
have been a little bit worried yeah well
we were a little bit do you want to go
and get rated actually yeah yeah go and
get ready to bring her in and she can
she can sort of say hello
um obviously
um you have to keep calm in the car so
it was a bit panicky because like I said
my sister only lives 20 minutes down the
road and even though we knew snow was
coming it was forecast for later that
night and we just got caught out I feel
really stupid
um not enough snacks in the car for the
kids luckily they had warm coats on but
it was a real big lesson I've always
lived in a city this is my first winter
out of town and we just got caught out
even though we thought it was say hello
to Uncle Neil
foreign
weren't as lucky
at like I I suspect you've got your
hands full a little bit this morning and
uh yeah someone probably wants to get
out probably wants to get out and enjoy
the snow for a little bit so we'll let
you go
I just want you to give me a wave before
you go Ray and please look at yourself
big wave
foreign
take care guys and have a lovely
Christmas when it comes